Teams have players.
A baseball team has nine players.
Each player is important.
The pitcher is very important.
She pitches the ball to the batter.
The batter is very important.
He hits the ball the pitcher pitches.
The catcher is very important.
He catches the ball the pitcher pitches.
The infielder is very important.
She catches the ball the batter hits.
The outfielder is very important.
He catches the ball the batter hits.
All the players are important.
To win, a team needs each player.
Baseball is a team sport.
Players play together to win.
Look at that boy. He is very tall.
Right. He is the tallest in my class.
Can you solve this math problem?
No, I can't. It's too hard to me.
Can Sarah solve this then?
Yes, she is very smart.